this place is my repetition my legacy
when the smoke clears I promise you
imma beat it game she'll be picky blood
everywhere none of them hoots
we had bullet holes in his shirt how did
he not get hit my shotgun blast
alone should've Julia you're amazing I
don't want to be different than anybody
else people need you
cops can only do so much
Harlem's about control power politics is
where the power is this next is like me
that let you hold on to what you got you
never really know what anyone is capable
of
[Music]
there is nothing that can hurt you so
what the hell are you our freedom is
Knights
is Queen you need to find his weakness
and you squeeze don't be a hero
another hero tape looks to me like
that's what you've always been
now take you to war you don't have
enough people no man it's you
oh man PLO Styles might enjoy back in
the day and sweet Christmas you a double
XL
oh yeah D you homie hey youtubers is
charlie new Luke Cage trailer full
season is dropping this Thursday night
at midnight so let's break it down Luke
Cage mowing through all of cottonmouths
dudes is really awesome but probably the
best part of this trailer is the Method
Man in tag at the end of this where he's
like I don't I don't have time for this
like he sees this mugging happening at
this little bodega and we get a Stan Lee
cameo giving him a call to action see a
crime reported so he goes in and it's
like oh man it's you and it's met like
Method Man recognizing Luke Cage as the
hero of Harlem no man it's you pielo
style was my jam back in the day and
they just automatically swap hoodies
because Luke Cage needs a new one sick
and tired always having to buy new
clothes so expect lots of little tags
like that in this I think that might
even be from the first episode if not at
least the first couple of episodes but
the other big thing in this is we
finally see
cottonmouths nightclub which is kind of
like this central location for the
series I think I mean it looks kind of
like Minton's jazz club it's like this
historic Harlem jazz nightclub from the
1940s where people like Charlie Parker
Dizzy Gillespie Thelonious Monk played
so that might be what they're going for
with this but like even if you haven't
been to Harlem you know the Apollo
Theater is a really big central venue
that a lot of people go to but this is
more of a nightclub like he talks about
it this is my legacy I think I explained
the relationship his character has with
alfre woodard scare achter they're kind
of like cousins
in the trailer it just spells that a
little more clearly like he uses his
crime to keep her in control she's kind
of like the politician kind of like the
more public face of Harlem sort of like
the Baron von Strucker - Mariah's Red
Skull in mariah is her name in while she
doesn't look really excited about
cottonmouth killing all these people
like she watches him Chuck that dude off
the building I'll be interested to see
if it's a jeryn hogarth twist like in
jessica jones jeryn hogarth is kind of a
good character but kind of a dirtbag in
that she's a lawyer who will do anything
to accomplish her goal so she winds up
being a villain by the end of the series
but then sort of turns back from the
edge of darkness so maybe that'll happen
with Mariah's character because really
like the kingpin is the biggest villain
of all cottonmouth will be the most
obvious villain like the guy who's
literally like punching this dude to
death til there's blood all over his
clothes but the really cool thing I know
everybody pretty much assumed this but
the showrunner on Luke Cage was talking
about Heroes for Hire in season two the
bad news of it and I don't really
consider it bad news is that he said
that they didn't have room for that in
season one which I think we kind of
assumed I think the general assumption
when it comes to Netflix series is that
if it's like their first outing like
this is the first season of Luke Cage
then it's mostly just going to be Luke
Cage and his Universal characters and
somebody else might get tagged at the
end like iron fist so in your mind
you're thinking Heroes for Hire
even though literally it's not happening
on screen so I think that's what he was
talking about when he said they didn't
have time for Heroes for Hire like
they're not gonna team up misty Knight
isn't gonna start going out with iron
fist at the end of Luke Cage season one
there's just too much to accomplish and
setting up these characters so think
about all that in season two but that
you know mean pretty much confirmed that
they're gonna do location season two I
think when it comes to Netflix series
because they've already been saying that
Luke Cage is one of the best ones that
they've done so far is that they'll keep
making these until the actors don't want
to do them anymore
so I would guess at least five seasons
of each of these shows like we're
already on daredevil season 3 which will
happen after defenders but speaking of
which they're getting ready to film
defenders and there was the whole video
I did about
during the iron fist I'll put a link to
that at the end of this video because
New York Comic Con is coming up they
will be dropping a new Iron Fist trailer
at that and just like with daredevil you
know they drop the Luke Cage teaser
trailer at the end of daredevil like at
the end of the 13th episode probably
gonna be the same thing with iron fist
so once you watch that 13th episode the
credits will roll then they'll show the
Iron Fist trailer so make sure you stay
through the end of Luke Cage episode 13
but all the episodes will drop Thursday
midnight on the 29th so if you have the
day off from work on Friday or you don't
have school I recommend you just roll at
least like three or four episodes it's
gonna take me about two days to get
through everything but I'm only gonna be
posting my video for the first couple of
episodes Friday afternoon so no worries
I'm like I'm not gonna rush it or
anything like that but then the rest of
my Luke Cage videos will just post like
one every couple days for each couple of
episodes so there'll be like four or
five Luke Cage videos for all the
episodes then I'll do some stuff about
Heroes for Hire season 2 iron fist
Punisher all the stuff that they might
be doing in the future based on what
happens during Luke Cage but we haven't
seen it yet so we can't really speculate
what they're gonna do in season 2 beyond
what the showrunner has said about doing
Heroes for Hire but that should be
enough to get you hyped just like oh my
god he actually said it they're actually
gonna do it and of course they would do
it why would you not do Heroes for Hire
if you had the opportunity but there is
new Superman
Supergirl season 2 footage so that's
gonna be my next video today so be sure
to subscribe to get that
and because pretty much every other
superhero show is coming back in the
next week or so there'll be a bunch more
trailers dropping this week so there'd
be more flash arrow more Marvel trailers
and there is new Ghost Rider dropping
tomorrow so my video will post Wednesday
morning for that just because it's a
10:00 p.m. show and I know a lot of you
are asking will Ghost Rider crossover
with the Netflix series anything is
possible just pay attention when they go
to big conventions like New York Comic
Con and people will probably ask them
they're usually good about giving
answers like hey anything is possible
like sometimes they won't confirm big
stuff like that but they'll keep teasing
you like oh you know we could work out
something because they definitely have
the budget to do those special effects
but at least for now I think goes dry
is just gonna be specific to agents of
shield future seasons all bets are off
though because I think you know once
they do go strata to this season they'll
move on to something else in season five
of agents of shield leaving Ghost Rider
free to float around the Marvel Universe
but let me know in the comments what are
you guys plans for binging Luke Cage do
you watch episodes one at a time or do
you try to watch the entire thing in one
sitting that's actually getting pretty
hard especially considering that most
people have gone back to school or they
have jobs
it's just that unless it's the middle of
the summer and you have the week off
from work or you don't have school it's
really hard to sit through 13 hours of
television in one sitting but new
Superman posting in just a little while
so get hype it's gonna be awesome
where you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that punisher iron
fist video and you can click here for my
thor funny moments super cut thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight